[Music]
you've been obsessed with everything
Edgar Wright has ever made and
everything he hasn't made now prepare to
be obsessed with a movie he's been
obsessed with for the last 22 years 22
dang if he'd made it back then onca
would have been an actual baby driver
baby driver meat baby 20 17s chiefest
Halloween costume he's a Mozart with a
go-kart but a Dane Cook of being a crook
whether he's using his criminal alias in
public name time baby
Vav robbers wearing the same outfit
before during and after his heists not
wearing gloves are wiping down his
prints and making his own recorded
evidence of criminal conspiracies why
don't any of these criminals work with
his snitch he doesn't even have a neck
tat that's that you know someone doesn't
have a real job get ready for awesome
stunt driving like you wouldn't believe
cuz baby's got more skills behind the
wheel then that other mostly silent
hearthrob with a signature jacket in the
movie with driving the title featuring
jaw-dropping getaways that are one part
bullet one part iPod commercial and
three parts
okay go video
but there's more than just automotive
thrills strap it in for tightly
choreographed gunplay money stacking and
scene after scene of white boy dancing
okay
all right
they stop
cut it out baby Jesus never get on my
nerves just give him the sandwich baby
strap it in for babies last job for the
creepy bank-robbing ringleader doc who's
even more creepy because he's played by
a pre scandal Kevin Spacey who's even
more creepy because he says stuff like
this to a young man you are my lucky
charm who's even more creepy because he
carries a little box of kids toys around
with him yeah we just put christopher
plummer space on him that's better
and speaking of creepy experience a love
story between a boy and the girl who's
clearly a stand-in for the boy's dad mom
as Debbie sings to baby just like mom
used to feeds him off the children's
menu you know that's a kids menu right
and works at the same diner that she did
she used to work here sometimes but uh
she was a singer too I guess
Oedipus driver doesn't quite have the
same ring to it anything about that baby
mom and dad here getting it home do you
like music
not as much as I do right you plebe
buckle up for a soundtrack full of songs
to obscure for the awesome mix Egyptian
reggae but too mainstream for Tarantino
plus a recording studio so adorkable
it could take Zooey Deschanel but in an
overall musical experience that will
have you revving your minivan on the way
to soccer practice
oh I'm the cool dad so if you're too
much of a hipster to like Fast and the
Furious enjoy Edgar Wright school lo-fi
conflict that was his highest performer
at the box office today even though he
doesn't even drive a single baby Oh
false advertising now boss baby there's
a film that delivers on the title story
babe ace kids drift raper Punisher
towaway zone
driving this crazy downshift a bee
freeway the baby from American sniper
earth explaining what tinnitus is Tenno
what he had an accident when he was a
kid he still got a humming the drum yes
sir
is tonight a song and can the
Christopher Plummer bananas read that
auto right city your real name is Miles
great because I needed more help getting
miles Taylor Ansel Elgort and the ready
player one guy confused what is your
major malfunction numbnuts taco CAD
spelled backwards is tacocat
birdie-birdie
in the sky why'd you do do in my eye
do not worry I won't cry I'm just glad
that cows can't fly people are stupid
but at least we have cotton candy